As you might expect, Android stores
your persistent data in the file system.
To simplify what app developers
need to write, Android provides
several structured storage options
on top of the file system.
For Sunshine, we'll leverage both Shared
Preferences and an SQLite Database.
Let's look at both of these options.
The Shared Preferences class, which we
are already using to store our user
zip code in units, provides a general
framework that allows you to save and
retrieve persistent key value
pairs of primitive data types,
such as Booleans, floats,
ins, longs and strings.
There are times when a simple key value
pair framework like Shared Preferences
doesn’t provide enough flexibility.
Fortunately, Android also has SQLite.
SQLite implements a light
weight relational database.
We interact with SQLite
databases by writing queries and
statements and SQLite's variant of
the structured query language or SQL.
Storing something in a a database
is more complicated than using
Shared Preferences.
So why would we ever choose this option?
After all,
Android supports both raw files and
shared preferences as alternatives.
Well, for the same reason that it's
inefficient to find things if you
throw your clothes in
a pile on the floor.
Storing things in an SQLite Database
helps you organize and find data easily.
Thanks to the power of indexing and
tables.
Let's see what this looks like.
Here is an SQLite Database table
from our weather database.
Note not all fields are represented.
All of the data for
the first day is in the first row.
The data for the second day is
in the second row and so on.
With key valued pairs,
it would be difficult to
associate a row of data this way.
As you continue through this section
on database storage and Android.
We're going to expect some basic
understanding of SQLite and
relational databases,
including what a create, select,
update, delete and insert operation is.
We'll help you write these operations.
But if you are new to SQLite or
need a refresher,
head over to the tutorial linked
in the instructor notes below.
Once we have a database up and
running on our device for our app.
Getting the information we
need using SQL is easy.
We can perform queries against this
database, such as this SELECT statement
here, which returns the weather
on the specified date.
Similar to what we would want to do for
the detail view.
We can use this slightly more complex
query to return a range of dates,
which is similar to what we'd do
on the main forecast list view.
Once again, if any of this was
unfamiliar, please consider working
through the SQLite tutorial
link in the instructor notes.
And even if isn't unfamiliar,
you might just learn something.
Okay.
Here's a slightly more
complicated SQL query.
See the instructor notes for
some resources that you can use
to help parse the SQL statement.
One note, max is the name of the column
that stores the high temperature for
the day.